[Musique]
il ya une liste qui clairement par
rapport à la position de départ a fait
bouger les lignes
celanese des républicains cette liste
qu'on a construite autour du
rassemblement de la droite et du son
emmanuel macron ne partira pas marine le
pen dit ça parce que c'est le moyen pour
elles d'obtenir un vote massif pour tous
ceux qui veulent le départ d' emmanuel
macron mais il ne partira pas c'est un
grand bluff et c'est bien dommage parce
que c'est au détriment des arguments de
fond et des propositions pour l'europe
parce que justement sur l'immigration
effectivement elle n'apporte pas de
solutions marine le pen et contre tout
ce qui vient de l'europe y compris quand
c'est l'intérêt de la france ce qui est
quand même assez désolant si vous voulez
c'est qu'on en soit réduit à voter
contre contre c'est à dire contre marine
le pen et contre emmanuel macron parce
que c'est ça la vérité on dit aux gens
attention voter marine le pen pour
pâques emmanuel macron sortent gagnants
ou voter emmanuel macron pour pas que
marine le pen sortent gagnants
gouvernement qui se met derrière
l'attaqué l'oiseau est d'ailleurs le
président l'effacement des affiches non
seulement c'est aussi cette président
uniquement du clan la république en
marche moi je ne lui conseille pas de
effectivement de se mêler des campagnes
européennes un chef de l'état d'être le
président de tous les français
et si demain il est candidat
eh bien il sera le président de 20% des
français 20% dès gens qui ont voté c'est
à dire en réalité ça t'a vu % du corps
lorsqu'un président de la république est
obligé de venir au chevet sa candidate
lorsqu'un président la république est
réduit à se mettre sur une affiche alors
qu'il n'est pas lui-même candidat
j'estime que c'est triste et qu'au fond
ils n'ont plus grand chose à dire ils
n'ont plus grand chose à proposer
ils n'ont personne a affiché aujourd'hui
on a la chance d'avoir avec laurent
wauquiez françois-xavier bellamy
et d'autres personnes qui partent à la
conquête des européennes des personnes
qui incarnent à la fois l'expérience le
renouveau mais aussi des convictions
être de droite je pense que c'est être
fidèle à ses idées emmanuel macron pour
l'élargissement
nous sommes contre je pense que c'est
une profonde ra le programmes des
manuels macron ne mentionne même pas
l'islamisme non pense que c'est un des
sujets majeurs
troisième exemple et on est une des
seules listes à le porter je pense qu'il
faut que l'europe retrouve la fierté
tout ce qui est sa culture qu'on a le
droit d'aimer ce que nous sommes et et
quand aujourd'hui emmanuel macron nous
propose de faire plus d'élargissement de
l'europe
quand emmanuel macron nous propose de
créer dans une seule lettre plusieurs
comités commissions agence banques
institutions supplémentaire quand
emmanuel macron nous propose de dépenser
de plus en plus d'argent public c'est
quand même le premier
la première formule qui vient dans cette
expression de du programme des macros il
faut créer une banque du climat et on va
dépenser 1000 milliards d'euros bon ben
voilà c'est typiquement une politique
classique de la gauche
c'est cette politique qui ne fonctionne
pas qui ne résout pas les problèmes
[Musique]